[موسيقى]
ومع قرار المانيا مؤخرا بارسال دبابات عقب
الخطوه الامريكيه بارسال دبابات ابرامس
حلفونات الان اقوى من اي وقت مضى اثر
الطلب الذي تقدمت به اوكرانيا لمساعدتها
في تحرير اراضيها من المحتل الامبريالي
الروسي واعتداءاته وعلينا ان نلاحظ ان هذه
هي الحرب الاولى لقوه النوويه في تاريخ
البشريه بالتالي فان الناتو لا عن
اوكرانيا بل يدافع عن العالم كله في وجه
هذه القوه الامبرياليه التي تذكرنا بعهد
النازيه حين سعى هتلر لبناء المانيا
العظمى من خلال ضم الاقليه الالمانيه في
انحاء البلاد ويبدو بوتين وكانه يحذو حذوه
بضم الاقليه الروسيه في دول الجوار وقال
بصريح العباره ان هدفه هو دفع قوات الناتو
الى الوضع الذي كانت عليه قبل
1997 اي عندما لم يكن في تحالف الناتو دول
من شرقي اوروبا اي دول الاتفاق وارسو
وفكرته هي بناء روسيا حديثه
[موسيقى]
نحن نرى هذه الحرب على انها الاولى لهذا
الجيل الخامس بمعنى استخدام الاسلحه
والانظمه التكنولوجيه المتقدمه وقد كانت
المسيرات التي وصلت من احدى دول الناتو
وهي تركيا مفيده جدا لاوكرانيا لكن في
نهايه الامر عندما تكون هناك قوه احتلال
تسيطر على اراضيك عندها يتسنى عليك
استعاده الاراضي بعمليه عسكريه بريه اي
بالدبابات والمركبات المدرعه وكان من
الطبيعي ان تطالب اوكرانيا في هذه الحاله
بالحصول على دبابات ولتحرير الاراضي انت
بحاجه الى قوه مشاه مسلحه ما يعني ارسال
المزيد من السلاح والذخيره لاوكرانيا
وربما ايضا قوه جويه لان القوه الجويه
فيها تقديم التغطيه والدعم للمشاه في
معارك تحرير الاراضي لكن الولايات المتحده
قالت انها ليست مستعده لذلك الدعم الجوي
بعد وان الامر يعود لاوكرانيا في ان تحدد
الاسلوب والاستراتيجيه والعمليات التي
ستعتمدها لتحرير اراضيها
[موسيقى]